hey guys this is going to be a status
update video and I'm also going to tell
you a little bit about myself in my
channel as of April 30th I've been on
YouTube now for over a year and I
reached 5,000 subscribers a few weeks
ago and I like to first off thank each
and every one of my subscribers every
single one of you guys for all of your
support for your comments ratings and
for just watching my videos and making
my channel what it is today you guys are
really awesome and I really have a lot
of fun teaching you guys and showing you
all the things that I enjoy and I'm just
so glad that I've been able to help so
many thousands of people and I would
like to say that if you did enjoy one of
my videos or something that you learned
you should go out and share it with
someone else so that they can enjoy it
also I decided to start my youtube
channel shortly after I became
interested in solving Rubik's puzzles
and the first cube that I learned how to
solve was the keychain cube I solved it
using the petrous method that I learned
from the Lars Petrus website the petrous
method is good because it doesn't waste
a lot of moves however it's very
intuitive and requires you think a lot
so when I first started out as a
beginner solving with the petrous method
I was able to get it down to around
three minutes but I wanted to solve it
faster so I checked out the Rubik's comm
website and I came across the Tison mal
method which is similar to the frederick
method and i was able to get it down to
about a minute or so but i didn't like
the way that the last layer was solved
in the mal method so i actually merged
the petrous method and the Tison mal
method into the method that i also
taught in my videos and i found that it
was a lot easier and beginner friendly
and people were able to solve it in
under a minute actually so I was
teaching friends and family and other
people and they recommend that I start
putting videos online which is how my
youtube channel got started within a few
months my Rubik's Cube videos we're
getting several thousand hits and also
getting pretty good feedback so I
decided to email the rubix comm website
to see if they possibly wanted to use my
videos to help others who might visit
their site so the senior vice-president
of the Rubik's brand actually sent me an
email back saying he'd love to add my 3
by 3 4 by 4 and the 5 by 5 to 2
on to their site in the Academy section
and he also sent me a very nice
thank-you package that I go over in my
cube collection video and he included a
t-shirt a tote bag a Rubik's 5x5
retooled cube and I thought that was
very nice of him you might have noticed
that many of my videos are about cubing
however I have a wide variety of
interests and hobbies as you can see on
my channel profile and I've been trying
to make some videos and tutorials so
that i could teach and share some of the
other things i enjoy with you guys the
origami models I think are really fun to
make and I also have a lot of fun making
the tutorials and teaching you guys
especially because it's not as
complicated as solving Rubik's cubes
it's just folding paper and I can kind
of do the tutorial in one day without
having to write down anything or script
anything which I started doing for my
rubik's tutorials
after the 3x3 so you should definitely
check out my origami tutorials which
went over pretty well with my
subscribers and also a lot of new
viewers if you want to learn how to make
the I also like playing pool
[Applause]
you
art and drawing is something I've been
passionate about ever since I was very
young and you might have seen my other
portrait video that I have up we already
have some other portraits but this is my
most recent piece I've been working on
this for over 12 hours a total time and
just before as you saw on video I was
trying to finish it up a little bit so
it's pretty much done
I just have to kind of work on the hair
a little bit and possibly some of the
shading and then it's complete it takes
me a little bit longer than my friend
the portrait art who does it in around
two hours and he has really good speed
drawing videos up so you definitely want
to be sure to check those out
you cannot defeat me stupid ball now go
get down ah oh oh ah didn't with it
there is that ladies and gentlemen is
why you should always juggle with your
vq5 and not an East chin cube so you
don't have to play 111 piece pick up
alright so besides all the hobbies and
other things I enjoy doing I also have a
pet cat Lila who I adopted from an
animal shelter about two years ago you
want to say hi Lila no okay you can go
anyway my birthday is June 29 1985 and
that's why I have the zero 6 to 9 in my
name so I'm 23 years old I am
left-handed as you might have seen in
some of my videos but I use my right
hand for the majority of things like
throwing or batting bowling
it's basically my stronger hand my left
hand I use for writing for eating for
brushing my teeth anything that requires
a utensil as far as TV shows I enjoy
watching lost heroes but I prefer to
watch National Geographic and Discovery
Channel the Science Channel stuff like
that teaching and making YouTube videos
is something that I do in my spare time
I graduate
from college in May 2007 with a Bachelor
of Science in biology and I've been
working the past two years at my
brother's dental office assisting
getting to know the different procedures
instruments and it's overall been a
great experience
I like dentistry a lot because it has to
do with both art and science two things
which I really enjoy so I applied to
dental school and I was recently
accepted for the fall 2009 semester
which starts August 30th of this year so
that's pretty exciting news for me and I
just wanted to let you guys know because
I'm not sure exactly how often I'm going
to be able to upload videos after that
point dental school is like a full-time
job it's a four-year intensive program
and I'm going to be happy having to do a
lot of studying so I hope you guys will
understand I'm not going to have as much
time to make videos but I will upload
new videos as often as possible so I'm
still going to be making the videos that
I had originally planned to create the
ones that I have listed under my
featured video I know that there have
been a lot of requests for how to get
faster at the 3x3 cube and I definitely
like to teach you guys some optimal ways
of solving this this is uh this is high
on my priority list I'd like to show you
guys how to possibly lubricate it what
types of cubes you'd like to get and
especially how to get faster with
solving the bottom two layers whereas
which is where a lot of time is lost in
the beginner method so as far as the
seven by seven cube goes I know there's
been some requests for how to solve the
seven by seven cube and make a tutorial
on that but I definitely don't think
that a full tutorial would be necessary
you can apply the six by six method that
I taught to the seven by seven cube
especially the centers and how you would
solve the last two I know that the last
two centers are tricky so I might have
some sort of video on that and possibly
the edge parity errors which can also be
solved using the 5x5 cube our algorithms
that I have in my part 4
um I'd also like to teach you guys how
to juggle three balls now I know you
guys you guys have seen me juggle cubes
and stuff like that and you just saw my
5x5 East shinky break into a million
pieces but I would definitely like to
teach you guys how to juggle and I feel
that anyone could do it with a little
bit of practice so people seem to like
the origami tutorials that I had it was
something that I just came up with I
actually found an origami book and I
became interested again and they were
pretty easy tutorials for me to make it
took me one day to make each of them
whereas the Rubik's cubes tutorials as I
said as I've said take a long time so I
would also like to do some possibly some
voice impersonation videos you've
probably seen some other videos where
I've done some sort of voice important
personation
or accent and I'd also like to do a
video contest possibly and I'd like some
ideas from you guys
so that I could possibly give away a
cube or something like that to the
winner all right so I need you guys to
give me some feedback on what tutorial
or video you think should be made next
do you have any other questions or
comments or new ideas requests leave a
video response or a comment below and I
will be frequently checking up on them
to see what the majority of the people
want and as always thank you very much
for watching and please subscribe for
notification of my videos